[Music]
Apsara gentlemanlike die [ __ ] they
prepare BMP just aquellos animal I am
Raja Hegel
[Music]
here are the mileage his open tally
Matilda malama map I'm above our Sigma
call sato-san Santo body bag abandon me
but data malama total shivanand a
Maharaja mean wanna main pocket
Ashkenazi kitty
[Music]
[ __ ] the door over the yapanese to solve
the malossi old poet as you may know the
Bellagio loose and a cheese have to
condemn elog desi Italian material
pocket arroba remember your Arabic a
irrevocable audible yachtsman open wanna
get out there Navarre
Roman Emperor Shah Baba Yaga Atika if
they cook in Akina the star that Java
pocket echidna Java Roberto gets their
photo photo photo America's original
jjigae is open drop and lock headed
America's enemy kuzava
Menno pakistani mehndi ball cozy olya
boy with our ma ki dal makini India mask
are many positive about Joe DiMaggio
Bonilla empanada Ghana
[Music]
goody we can grow giant models for foot
in a month 45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model nice and tender
unless some of them look a bit tough but
once you cut into them they cut like
butter my name is Phillip Falls I live
in San Ari Wales and I grow giant
vegetables I've been growing giant
vegetables now for the last 30 years I
come from a very large family
my mother had 17 children 13 of us
survived and I think you know that was
something you know big vegetables feed
big families you know I'm up here every
morning every night every single day of
the week there's a lot of love and cake
was into it sometimes I do able to talk
into them as well to encourage them to
grow which is a bit of a bit of fun you
know I think he's just about finished
growing there now I got to be very
careful the wife is not about when I
start talking to my vegetables but it's
all good fun I broke the world record
for the area's cucumber about 25 years
ago it radiates in a half pound and it
was just incredible the way true you
know when I started if we had a Mauro 20
30 pound in weight you are the bait
Mauro now we're up over and rappelling
weight
normal cabbage would be to pound in
weights but we're growing I'm 120 pound
you know you can feed 120 hundreds 240
people off one cabbage this is why I
supply the local pub and they use a
mapper Sunday lunch I've developed my
own strain more or less now I select my
own seed every year the biggest and the
best see and it's just seems to be
improved
which is incredible I grow organically I
do think if I can do it anybody can do
it and it's a big thrill every day the
wife say what am i doing up a lot went
every day and when she comes up she
realized see page c page play play page
what the hell is page playing this is an
orchestra comprised entirely of fleets
this works because flutes can cover the
entire range of an orchestra on their
own from the piccolo at the top all the
way to the double Concha bass flew down
at the bottom very cool and there's
Paige playing you know back from the
intro I'm Paige long and I'm a
professional flutist wait flutist or
flautist
I like flutist she's one of a handful of
people playing the three largest flutes
in the flute family the Contra bass
flute the sub contrabass flute and the
double Concha bass flute let's learn
about big flutes in its case the double
Contra bass flute weighs approximately
thirty pounds it stands over eight feet
tall and it's 22 feet of too big the sub
contrabass flute in G has 11 feet of
tubing and the Contra Basin C has 9 feet
of tubing so how does one play an
instrument with 22 feet of tubing for
these lower flutes it's a whole
different technique your embouchure is
looser new word embouchure um sure
embouchure embouchure is the way you
shape your mouth to make a sound on the
flute your mouth is looser bigger takes
a lot more air and a lot more support I
feel like I've run a 10k when I'm done
with a concert because it's hard to get
a clean low sound they actually play the
lowest possible notes of an orchestral
instrument say Louis of any orchestral
instrument now what does that mean hey
guys can you help us out here well
alright ready boys the double contrabass
flucos low lower than any instrument can
go low then stream is a big old guy he
mates that bass on fly and what's next
it's the sub contrabass flute hit it
another big flute sounds like a bassoon
the sub contrabass can carry a tune the
contrabass flute is the smallest fellow
it sounds just like a cello
wow thanks now I understand so Paige
what do you like about these giant
flutes in the land of flutes they're
like the subculture of the flute
community and we provide a role that the
concert flute cannot
it all checks out Paige play us out
[Music]
I just want to start and go and go and
go the longest amount of time that I can
draw before the tide comes in and watch
their anyway my name is Jim Donovan I
draw in the sand to draw on the sand
it's a balance between a mental game and
a physical they're both equally
important I started drawing in the sand
a little more than 20 years ago I was
walking along the beach one day it just
came to me to use it as a canvas I just
put my finger in the sand and made a
giant fish I became really really
obsessed with it I left behind the world
both of surfing and the job as a chef
and I just took everything it's a
drawing in the sand there's almost no
one in the whole world that did this
kind of thing I've drawn in the sand
around the world Australia Uruguay
Argentina Chile brush I mean
occasionally a commission but also in
places where others a nice patch of sand
I think I'll go do something there the
one that was 10 miles in circumference
in the desert on dry lake
Zacchaeus world record and largest art I
walked as much as 30 miles in one day
which means about seven or eight hours
of walking I like the stick probably the
best because I like to come down to the
beach with nothing the tools are sitting
there on the beach sticks to choose from
and I'll do my composition do a nice big
drawing and then I'll throw the stick
away I'm down with nothing and leave
with nothing
for me that's most fulfilling choice of
how to do it
during the sand is the ultimate of in
the moment and I want to finish when the
tide is about to destroy the time this
is gonna change every day anything I do
down there is going to be gone and every
time I'm gonna have a big huge place to
try something there robot political
anime La Tengo Central Television
meeting pseudo coconut design unit at
all yadda Singapore you could tell I
don't like New York on the Borodino
screech I do Tory Cusimano Mochaccino
you met Mitch Qadri take it portable
optimum
[Music]
standing at 28 feet and weighing in at 5
tonnes the LW munna no foo is a
life-size robot that was built by one
man here w-well no no who say it's a
quick stop and I wore my sock you do
seem to reach it in got housing me my
state machines you've done on it no
local income or 3 years to take up with
- my stop
Masaki works as an engineer at
Sakakibara a company that develops
machines for agriculture but they also
make life-size robots that people can
operate for fun and Misaki along with
his colleagues have built them all
she will not corrode Acadia soon enough
they operate
Nicole Bogle what caste original to you
aku variegata Papa yeah party so they
did I could be whatever them lucuma not
an Aussie to conquer death will not cook
them so when masa is JA tasked him with
creating a robot to help promote the
company he referenced one of his
favorite animes as a kid right Gundam -
you know you're freaking my stage
haasvelt oppa kids are you differently
just I grandmother Domino for a meter a
quinoa have an Okie no he does to you
cough I though she TT that's how it's a
bologna conjugated mono screen titled it
captain but just building the robot
wasn't enough for Misaki he wanted
something that was bigger and better
than his previous models he poured his
heart and soul into making the LW mana
no foo
fully operational it could move its arms
its legs and as a gun that shoots sponge
balls it's his greatest creation yet
what's good machine that's good didn't
it was greatest task no high school
Aikido solution my see your whatever see
Tomica diameter more so by athenian
inaudible quite a lot of this node a
beautiful little chick I'd a fairy
mother mother what are you know right it
will not watch Emma I mean who could not
start not so over sitting on a scooter
taman negara hydrocodones nanny consider
its co-op the second victim she's an
autumn well okay
nope a German tornado no honey I'm okay
but you want no time I'm not good to use
she's a journalist kiddo Cosima take
about what was written about quitting
the night Pokemon
[Music]